what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna watch today a first time
watching put Dungeons and Dragons
joined by someone who's been coming this channel
for years now the Tara Eric Sentara how's
it going dear hi I'm good did you hear my
dragon more while you were talking yes it's
called solid grade A improv skills right there
bring in the a game today thank you so much
ladies and gentlemen follow Tara on her own
YouTube channel she does reactions there herself
as well it's the only way to keep her coming
back if she doesn't get more followers she
doesn't see any value in being I'm out of
here not even friendship and make up for it
guys you know what to do leave a like on this
video that would mean a lot Tara what do they
do with that Bell and ring the bell ring the
bell also full-length Reaction watch along
is where you single with your own copy of
Dungeons and Dragons honor amongst these is
available for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page thank you to all who have joined us there
so far we've gotten so many pledges we've
been doing so many movie reactions over there
and your support means the world to cover
a bunch of stuff exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and watch along's included
talking really fast without want this intro
to be too long but I wanted to say too thank
you everyone about a space baby shirt from
the real rejects shop zeroedition.com love
it we have sold so many it's on track to becoming
our new number one bestseller and this rejects
headband is a prototype testing it out right
now currently this current one squeezing my
head a little too tight I might have to be
rejected
oh my God yes let's watch this Tara let's
do it
[Music] I didn't ask have you ever played
D no never I played it one time a year ago
so all Easter eggs flying over our heads today
I don't even remember the trailer for this
one I had been invited to the D and D session
I didn't really want to play but it ended
up being a lot of fun
oh there's like a beast in there oh yeah
well what is that
whoa oh sweet hello sir that's hoga I'm edgin
and you are I've been in low cells never shared
one with a female think I'm gonna like it
oh holga doesn't love to be disturbed while
she's eating her potatoes kind of the highlighter
for day son of you we could be very happy
I'm gonna do this without fingers and make
it a mitten
not expecting his knees to snap back like
that that was that would look great I noticed
that Chancellor Jonathan is not present should
we perhaps wait Chancellor Jonathan was delayed
by the storm you may be surprised to learn
I wasn't always a thief
years ago I became a member of the Harpers
faction my wife Zia supported my decision
stop bandits in their tracks
and even bring fan red Wizards to Justice
Temptation I'd come home to my loving wife
and daughter Kira with the goal I just stole
when you were a Harper you were bound to make
enemies and sometimes those enemies come looking
for Revenge
oh no shoot oh
did they kill the the child too I don't hear
it uh where where oh thank goodness oh what
a good baby the baby was able to stay quiet
during this murder Cooperative baby [Music]
no Clara can repair the damage from a red
Wizard's blade there was no way to revive
her the red wizard oh he's scarred now astute
to observations Tara Eric's I'm sorry it's
just hard to relive this without Jonathan
here [Music] that's when I met hoga we quickly
became like brother and sister with a relationship
built on trust and mutual respect
we tried something new [Music] honor among
Thieves you may be wondering how we could
carry on this criminal lifestyle with a young
girl at home well we didn't leave her at home
we also added Simon a so-so sorcerer a con
man named Forge who pushed us to aim even
higher oh [__] you regret when we met
the wizard sophina that she wanted our help
in robbing Corn's keep that's a Harper stronghold
I don't know if you've heard of it I'm sure
Jonathan has [Laughter] Forge told me that
among the relics and Corn's keep there was
a tablet of Reawakening capable of bringing
back a single deceased person you can probably
see where this is going yes
[Music] she's handy oh she's cool
whoa what a neat effect [Music] is too powerful
foreign
[Music]
the
effects and designs in this movie are so good
pretty dope please wait for Jonathan oh awesome
oh he's cool
she's throwing potatoes oh
dude
oh
my goodness
[Music]
[Music] I hope they didn't just kill that
bird no not Jonathan his weird name should
live on forever I like how they'd established
the dynamic between Chris Pine and Michelle
Rodriguez it's just like a brother and sister
Dynamic it's like us Greg you could be your
sister you could you could be my very very
much much much older sister sure where do
you think Forge took her
glue
of course is never Wonder oh what a dick
oh that was awesome cool have you seen A Wrinkle
in Time no well Chris Pine going back to his
daughter after trying to do something right
but being lost another similar type of character
setup it's like a blend of that character
with his character from Wonder Woman oh yeah
he's so funny in Wonder Woman
oh
what the hell what's going on there obviously
I couldn't give back the treasures we'd stole
it Lord nevermber fairly ill I seized the
chance to try and couldn't have done it alone
and here she is oh I knew it she's the one
that got us caught not true no without her
we all would have been caught and since then
she has become my top advice sneaky business
of course that's right no it wasn't for me
it was for that tablet of riches it it's a
tablet of Reawakening I wanted to bring your
mother back I know how much you crave for
forgiveness but I promise you more lies is
not the what an [__] but you can't blame
the poor girl for distrusting you you have
been lying since you set foot in the room
haven't you what you grant is the villain
I was doing it for Mom for all of us you have
to trust me he told me to trust you when you
left me this is a pickle I don't think I will
be returning it or your daughter bastard
daughter for uh
handsome boy what do you
clean it with you're about to lose your head
this is what you're concerned with if you
wouldn't mind
boiled linseed oil
let's do it [Music] oh yes oh
yeah I just said the fact that I get rid of
this oh my God
oh she is awesome oh my goodness she is so
cool
[Laughter]
oh [__] yes
it's cool that ballet belongs with her I should
probably go speak to him no he's gone my dear
he's gone
the fact that you see good in me makes me
believe that there might just be something
I don't know Praise on her innocence I hate
it the days of rom-com Hugh Grant are gone
straight up villain now Bay we have to get
into that castle and take her out ourselves
we're gonna need a team goddamn right we have
nothing to pay them with Forge does he said
the richest people were coming to bed on the
high Sun games I think cure will know we abandoned
her for the right reason I wouldn't put it
like that
Simon's a terrible sorcerer I'm sure he's
got me better no one can hold a candle to
this trick [Laughter]
I don't really like this uh cool smart fan
sneaky is that don't drop it don't drop it
no no that's so much gold get him [Music]
whoa damn cool
oh
[Music]
that was awesome this movie shot so well like
insane there's such good style to it and I
love how there's like a great blend of practical
and visual effects Doric she's truly One of
a Kind Joe Justice cannot be killed on my
command you're good that's not Dory whoa I
oh [__] so cool that's her [Music] oh
that's what you want to date oh
oh okay much better much better
yeah get it ladies she looks like Sophia lillis
from uh it but I don't know about surf oh
no I think that is her is it her yeah I'm
not sure that if it's not she has a doppelganger
we're gonna take down Ford Fitzwilliam you're
the only one who can get into that castle
tell us what we're dealing with as you can
imagine I don't trust humans finding you to
be a little man exactly that you bring to
this I'm a planner you've already made the
plant so what valley do you have now
so you make plans that fail Ure
I love the tone of this movie disciple I rely
on most oh the eyes no
ah spooky if the alarm is raised nobody gets
in or out and then bug is a spy The Vault
itself it is protected by the Arcane seal
of modern Canaan what okay a big big strong
what does that mean big strong seal is what
it means a wild shape is Among Us
whoa
oh she couldn't catch it it's too small for
you oh damn shape-shift oh cool
it was her okay that's awesome
whoa cool Dale there's one hell of a shot
foreign
[Music] what a hell of a shot awesome just
keep it in the POV when shit's attacking too
that's great
oh yes yes cool oh what oh she could have
waited till you got out of the house girl
what an impressive sequence
turns one of the birds yeah oh no that's cruel
no meanie damn how can she detect it she's
a sense it
oh awesome the deer oh I got like oh no no
no no no no no damn
I got arm chills so there's no way to open
it well if we had the Helm of disjunction
it's a helmet that disables all nearby enchantments
but it doesn't matter the thing went missing
ages we're done find it search for helmet
now I have this token that lets me ask corpses
some questions and then they go back to being
dead after the evermore's thank you Simon
for the drinks I was told this movie was funny
I wasn't told how cool yeah this movie's rad
yeah this is a like a rock and roll Adventure
man I have not been bored once yeah
murder them all right bye
they do a lot of long shots where they stay
in it and they don't do a lot of tattoos and
I adore that I adore it too I just feel like
these Epic Fantasy Adventures nowadays are
so like serious and doom and gloom and imagine
just to be like really fun but also honor
the genre yeah and also has heart to it like
it's realistic which I like super enjoyable
it's like swashbuckling oh God is that proudly
Cooper yeah he's so tiny tiny Bradley I'm
surprised the first time we met him I thought
your sentence was longer it is I see you still
have that walking stick I gave you yeah well
you could you could take it with you if you
want Quinn's not much for rambling Glenn yeah
oh you know when you left I lost my family
I've been fortunate enough to find another
and I wish nothing less than that for you
this is so hot but it works we're going to
take down Forge I'm gonna show Marlon man
and the elk track they were fools to let me
go she got the closure sort of oh she got
it she's ready now
[Music]
I love them together they are amazing together
they make such good best friends
once the dead man is revived we can ask him
five questions at which point he will die
again never to be re-revived you should write
down your five questions yeah before asking
he prepared
maybe I'm not saying it oh my god wow one
more question right yes no that wasn't for
you did that count as a question no oh my
God only answer when I talk to you okay oh
my God why did you say Okay at the end of
that I didn't oh my God that was great oh
my God
we knew we outnumbered them but our advantage
meant nothing against the dragon Ray cool
Dungeons and Dragons
why aren't you gonna ask him the last three
questions what's your favorite food S no barley
what's two plus two I bad at math [Laughter]
I assumed the order
God I love the Aesthetics to deliver the helmets
to our swiftest Rider then we can just make
it over the ridge
that'll do it there was the morning of the
battle that's all stepped up my ball my foot
slipped on the stone oh no [Laughter] then's
my brother it's not all right
it's very like Edgar Wright Cuts yeah a little
bit great transitions I just needed to keep
the helmet safe it was a fan who bought the
mark of zast Tam I waited for the killing
blow I said Bridgerton guy yeah
sorry as I died he promised to keep the helmet
safe the helmet's a dead end will have to
find another way into the world no I've heard
of zinc the fans are murderers you're gonna
have to overcome it man I'm still alive what's
your favorite book test question right guns
of historical Works I'd say that was only
the fourth question oh no no please be alive
in a post credit scene let's cut back to him
I want it wow cool oh my god oh that's a big
kitty the variety in this movie
look at that that is so awesome
oh
that's so sweet oh that's so cute hey go talk
to him you know I've pulled cats out of fish
you know what this movie has a Whimsy and
wonder nothing either of us have nope never
have in our lives our reasons for launching
the helmets are entirely Noble I'm gonna Rob
some poga portraits William and the red wizard
of day is partnered with come with me all
right hot Bridgerton I'll go wherever you
go he's a very attractive male specimen all
his fellow rulers Tam had a plan of his own
to Stage an Unholy coup
wow
man that's an awesome shot oh my God does
it suck in all the bad juice cool enslaving
them to his will with the aid of his red Wizards
zastam created an army of the undead so there's
like a [__] ton of red Wizards what will
become of the wealthy burgle all divided amongst
the townspeople place your hand on this Harper's
seal and swear that you will indeed distribute
all the wealth you take amongst the people
of Neverwinter character
give forges money to the people of Neverwinter
you may not yet believe your words but I do
good for you Simon hold on
why would you put it down there because it's
just the last place that anyone who values
their life would go sounds lovely quite the
opposite I know I was being ironic I find
irony is a blade that could see who wields
it most of special I saw firsthand the horrors
of the spell Honorable Men turned to monsters
parents turning on their own child damn that
is beloved
all right ah oh the tiny just a tiny bit let's
see [Music]
this movie's so composed who would have thought
some oh so lived in they've stunned their
targets and consumed the brain taking control
of the body the higher the intelligence of
the prey the more likely they are to strike
fascinating cool little walking brains oh
gross gnarly
oh that's a little hurtful yeah
like it didn't even sniff me there was a precise
formula we must follow so as not to trigger
the mechanism starting from the center use
odd numbered blocks only moving forward with
each step except for every fifth step which
must be a lateral move so it's very dangerous
it's a dragon Prince odd numbered blocks only
however at the midpoint we switched to even
numbers [Laughter]
thank you
I may have put my foot on the bridge can't
you just magic us across come on you can do
it confidence believe in yourself why did
you get that what Marlon's walking stick that's
not a walking stick
it's a hither stuff cool they got lucky did
the
it works they got really lucky yeah
this thing that you were protected with your
very life I will it drops [Laughter] that's
great oh that's where they all are the red
Wizards or the converted Army of the Dead
yeah they have assassins or that oh took a
lot of wrong guesses we were wrong
leave them to me
oh nice oh he's got this whole thing handled
oh [__] nice
[Music]
or about hogar oh come on
awesome awesome sick
[Music] oh oh yeah
quickly no thank you okay so they are the
r they are they are right here yeah
what was that Dragon I hope so
oh is it an owl what is it what it is oh my
god oh whoa is it a really fat dragon yeah
I think it's an overweight Dragon that's one
Punchy dress yeah you must have found a new
Den did he eat the last one oh my God it is
so fast slide [Music]
thank you [Music]
oh nice
whoa cool wow these perspective shots are
crazy
four big dragons [Music]
big ass
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that poor Dragon didn't do anything wrong
it was just a fat dragon there's just a Fat
Track [Music]
so are we
go inside its mouth and come out the other
end
[Music]
shaking off his Slumber
you're the planner you're the platter he's
the platter
cool smart must feel like a warm bubble bath
right about now who would not recommend this
movie idiots yeah anyone who didn't recommend
it certified get out yeah it's just way too
inventive This Is Where I Leave You Wish you
every success on your jet what you're so essential
and you're so hot
it's gonna walk back he's just gonna walk
back and keep being unfunny line oh wait a
minute he's coming up on a rock is he gonna
go around nope right over the Rock
oh that's hilarious they wrote that in I love
it
oh there he is the great Simon Omar oh my
great great grandfather
it chooses whom I wield it so I'm in
I'll try a different approach great you got
this you got it [Laughter] [Music]
I've never seen a bigger coward
oh this poor guy's just grieving so I'm trying
to capture it
you just have to let it go exactly exactly
there's a metaphor for you um this is exactly
what I told you would happen back at the tavern
but you wouldn't listen instead of dwelling
on what went wrong and who lied to whom let's
put our heads together and figure out a plan
I'm gonna figure out my way home yeah I'm
going to guys guys all cannot be lost we're
not done until my daughter's safe don't you
sick of failing no that's that he must never
stop
never stop we failed that's actually not bad
true failure rate of success I lost everything
that ever mattered to me and it was all my
fault one who really killed my wife I agreed
I did I decided we deserved a better life
than a Harper's oath would allow us oh he
called it but I didn't know that red Wizards
marked their treasure I led them right to
our door failed all of you which is exactly
why I can't quit so if you'll excuse me I'm
gonna go sit on this rock make a plan that's
why you got to give the money to the townspeople
we put the portal on something and then sneak
that thing into the Vault but there'd be dozens
of guards yeah but the guards would be guarding
against people taking things out of their
wagons not putting them in oh God could kiss
you that's right hmm [Laughter]
Cool Chris Pine really is perfect in these
kind of rules yeah that insanely good looking
funny guy everything a man or a woman wants
is basically yes
smart they're getting clever on knowing how
to use this device
oh that almost made me a little seasick but
I still loved it
no no no no
oh no oh I'm Boulder hurry hurry
oh
this is so creative cool
wow this movie has to have like 95 runtime
right yeah give me a break it's so cool it's
so good it's so imaginative and there's real
like Stakes too [Music] great
now he can do magic you know damn well I can't
attune to the thing that's not true you're
the gravity of a whole theater it was wild
magic and that only happened because they
were going to kill me exactly you need an
emotional pull you're backed into a corner
fight or flight baby use this to keep in contact
it is a setting Stone oh of course like a
walkie-talkie oh let's celebrate glasses well
once we can tend to end that's a real voice
I think so celebrate lasses
[Music] [Laughter]
[Music] that's so cool
Ah that's painful [Music]
just a minute
[Music] that's so cool oh dope ah she didn't
even need the helmet
yourself
or death time you're a Spain on your family
name so how with my name let me a tune you
had your time now it's my turn I won't allow
it I don't care whoa whoa sorry had to happen
what the hell took you long enough there we
go cool
just had to stand up for yourself kid hell
yeah oh man all right well done
[Laughter]
great I made it inside the Vault so did we
where are you where are you
what
oh oh is he like he's like moving on the oh
he left me I know you think I'm a liar and
a bad father but I am I am a bad father and
I wasn't trying to bring your mom back I was
trying to bring my wife back
is that his daughter it's not his daughter
no or oh it's a dark person
that was actually really well done CGI effect
when she can transform I hope you can take
comfort in knowing that she's with the father
she deserves I don't want to see you die which
is why put him in the games if you're gonna
kill us at least let us die with dignity put
us in the ice on games yes yeah I saw guards
loading everything onto a ship he was stealing
it for himself you never cared about being
Lord that just gave him access to the Vault
he must have brought back the game so the
take would be bigger smart guy if Forge is
leaving what does sophina get out of this
a bigger Army he does have like an Indiana
Jones quality about him huh yeah so we just
go through the maze I guess till we reach
the cage [Music]
oh
cool weapon
get it get it keep moving yeah oh [Music]
that's not fair uh sneaky
[__] [Music]
oh yeah that's right
poor tongue
oh yes oh another minute I would have lost
my hand yeah but look what you did lose come
on everyone get your hands in there yeah if
we survive this will be another challenge
in another until every last person in that
cage is dead if we have to find a workaround
when we hear the gong when we jump in you
want to end up like that guy we'll only be
inside for a few seconds if we're all inside
he's gonna pull us out I will trust me always
always hold
hold what's the [__] plan go
oh Smart Genius [Music]
get out of there cool get out of there I've
never liked a snake more I hate snakes
you said a second that's dangerous
so smart so smart
we gotta move
that is actually kind of scary quite a second
date yeah it's
hi honey it's the tablet of Reawakening Kira
it's the reason why I left you go home bring
back Mom we can be a family again you can't
bring her back you're not taking my money
put down the tablet and get off my ship that
took a turn he knows I'm prepared to do terrible
things to get what I want even to those I
care about most in the end evidently but
ah
[__]
oh my God
I've been fun oh my God you're Magic I hope
you can swim buddy
awesome that much Dragon action huh I mean
the fat dragon was cool but you're right
oh my God they're all gonna turn into the
her army with the red juice oh boy the red
juice on me coming in
uh yeah that's a lot of red juice Neverwinter
come on come on he knows what to do become
the suicide squad
oh you red Wizards oh man
pretty choke on her own greed what is this
oh no way awesome
oh that's fantastic you could hurt someone
put a helmet on yeah
it's smart get the mail out of the Coliseum
yeah that's really smart just did use your
pendant [Music] oh my God gee go and then
get the final blow
okay girl you're destroying your city you
know Overkill there's there's just four of
them right there I mean come on now
wow cool
all right
she missed nope nope she created a dragon
oh
it's Kong versus Godzilla this is always the
girl saving the guys in this movie and I love
it [Music] take it up come on show you're
more than a planner you can do it
yeah good plan
no no no
oh my God his back's gonna get so scratched
up
nice the littlest things I love it oh
gross
yes yeah sorcerer
wow what a intricate design so damn [Music]
oh [__] Super Smash Brothers hands [Music]
no no don't why would you just try to run
away oh no come on [Music]
oh you can catch yourself cool kind of still
hurts I'd imagine yeah
yes yes work together
the time stop
I'm so sorry
just as I begin to purge this place of its
living filth you dare interpose oh
ah sorry your breath just smells like that's
the old clothes it's bad
clever we had to distract you so Kerry could
slap on that cuff and so dork could do this
yes I think you got her a few more times wouldn't
hurt [Laughter]
yes I've actually really becomes the animals
you gotta be [__] me no you not killer
off it's a red Wizard's blade there's nothing
I can do
oh he's gonna have to use the thing to bring
her if they still have it oh to bring her
back instead of the mama promise me something
they're gonna take good care of our girl that's
her that is her mom
because he wanted to bring back his wife not
his mother not her mother but bring back the
mother I need you
yep oh that's so sweet [Music] the mom was
there for her all along this is such a kid
movie I love it so much [Music]
time you have to let it go Center shots
[Music]
don't tell me you wasted it on me
that's so touching hmm I wonder if you'd consider
having another go at it yeah all right yeah
yeah all right
he's got his whole family back lord nevermber
finally came too his first official Act was
to award the saviors of Neverwinter the medal
of heroism nice he granted formal protection
of their people and their land
pardon denied session is adjourned
Jonathan
poor Jonathan um
Bravo that was brilliant that was so good
that was yeah I cried a little bit at the
end yeah all right only got 15 minutes well
this guy had an appointment to get to break
it down then I mean you could take it away
first Tara what what'd you love about it I
love everything I love the cuts uh the Edgar
Wright moves I love that they have big long
shots but I also love there's some way there's
not a lot of movies that I think can add comedy
action and heart into the same movie and make
it all seem grounded like you believe the
moments and they're not like overly corny
I feel like all these moments everybody got
a moment where they got to prove themselves
or get like closure or find family and I believed
all of it like there wasn't a moment where
I was like that's a little heavy-handed like
why would they write that in um yeah yeah
all of the moments where they had to go and
seek a thing and get it for themselves and
their heart and their soul was bingo yeah
I think you're a hundred percent right on
the money when it comes to this one because
I know I said during the reaction while I
catch her name really quick is this Sofia
it is it 100 sure um yeah because like they
set up a great villain in this and this is
the kind of movie that could have easily just
been one that wanted to lean into just being
a comedy more so than anything else but I
thought they did an amazing job at really
really elevating it with the comedy and allowing
it to be something have a unique voice amongst
the fantasy epic genre where he usually is
it does all those things of like sprawling
Adventure a lot of locations a lot of different
creatures some good action scenes are we getting
a scene that's coming in right now I think
there is yes I win [Laughter] can somebody
please ask me another question anyone yeah
there's no way it played out I was like that's
like a post-created scene I love it um yeah
I think that when it I do oh if they're if
if they're recommending another movie to watch
that must mean there's no post credit scene
we'll let it play just in case um yeah the
who's also gonna say you were foreign
the women never listen oh no you were talking
about you were talking about uh the the action
in the in the um fantasy world moving into
the action all that stuff you were trying
to like was I yeah I was so distracted by
my victory that I just had it just flew right
out of your brain yeah that is where you were
headed I mean like we don't I've literally
played it once and the the game itself like
Wally can have a bunch of lore the the kind
of version I played and maybe this is just
how it always is where you kind of just make
up a bunch of stories it's a big improv game
it's a giant improv game I think you would
really like I would love that because what
always kind of turned me off I've ever wanted
a dabble in the game was I feel like I gotta
learn a bunch of [__] I don't want to
learn but it's not that it is just a bunch
of role-playing and and it is a hardcore improv
game and I love it I I loved it when I played
it that one time I just haven't hung out with
my friends who gain who did the d d gaming
nights ever since the amount of yeah just
you and I will make our own rules it's kind
of what you do you kind of make it you go
but as uh as with this they they brought all
that to life with the storytelling the constant
like coming up with stories and constant story
time but that just fits with the genre so
well and they they never made fun of what
the world was they never made fun of the genre
they had like some self-aware humor but it
never wanted to like step out of its way and
wink too much at the audience it was just
right where I was like I'm invested in the
journey I think I'm really into the Peril
I'm really into what the consequences are
here and I I care about the characters like
when Michelle Rodriguez was about to die at
the end I totally forgot about the the item
to that it could bring her back I was like
what and then they planted the seed so well
with that line that he had and they don't
even remind you they don't even they don't
do the exposition of saying right which I
enjoy they like let's let the visual language
just handle it for you right yeah I thought
that was great the the four main players were
awesome they all had uh especially the the
like the girl Sophia Lewis doesn't have like
a big character or she gets to have her cathartic
moment but the other three have their arcs
and especially coming the wrap around because
yeah the little girl did not know her biological
mom right this was her this was the mom she
grew up with and especially for having the
Dynamics of that between between uh in a movie
like this is usually they would be the ones
who end up together like there's no romantic
story other than the fact of Chris Pine grieving
uh over his wife there's no actual romantic
story that of him courting anyone in this
movie you know right which is nice for a change
because you don't really have to and hot Bridgerton
guy was not courting anyone either but he
is like he's good Justice he has some good
Justice good Justice he does good he's good
Justice the production design Tara amazing
that was shut up that one long shot I couldn't
with that I was like how does it how do you
even think of that and to weave in and out
like I'm always so curious how they design
that how they can shoot it there's obviously
going to be hidden Cuts between graphic design
and actual camera moves and I'm always like
how do they figure it out yeah it was sprawling
and swashbuckling throughout it just had that
that sense of adventure you don't really get
that much from I don't feel like you really
get that just genuine sense of fun adventure
yeah anymore you know I kind of reminds you
like when I saw Pirates of the Caribbean the
first time at the theaters just that like
fun adventure with like that modern day sensibility
but it's like it's a different time period
um and this leans much more to like fantasy
of course uh yeah I thought this was a really
just genuine great time and Chris Pine is
like so perfect in these girls he's so perfect
him and Michelle man I like it yes she gets
to show off some like comedic sensibilities
as well here uh where she usually is just
kind of like nowadays I see her more like
she's more just tough and here she gets to
be she got the best fight scenes she's such
a badass yeah so cool great choreography all
around oh I loved and especially how the women
were always saving the men because like the
back of the day it's always a man saving a
woman and like from the very first fight it
is both of the women who save the men I mean
they help out and whatever but for the most
part and I like that yeah and they don't like
draw a bunch that's true there's like no real
Damsel in Distress in this movie No thank
goodness like we don't need it like everyone
should just be strong and cool yeah and we
don't really need even the daughter wasn't
like they didn't put her in it of course when
she was like about to have her throat cut
by mean man yeah Dylan man but other than
that um everyone was smart and competent which
I like they didn't ever turn to the camera
either to be like I don't need a man saving
me right now right like I wasn't even thinking
about her until you like pointed it out like
oh yeah that's true look at them just kick
a bunch of ass yeah I love it and the editing
was so good too such impressive editing there's
like so many shots in this movie and it doesn't
feel like overwhelming or over stimulating
it it no it feels it's a smooth ride it's
[Music] [Laughter] I wish we were certified
critics so we could try to get that on the
poster it's like a catalog I'd probably be
in the theater look at that poster means what
is it it's like a Cadillac let's look at the
rotted Tomatoes what would you give the percentage
of this okay I am giving it 95 I really had
a great time I did not find any issues with
it but again I haven't played the game so
if y'all are DND like and it didn't deserve
that purpose 100 I'm like yeah but just look
at it as a film please give me a break it
was great it doesn't feel isolating at all
as people who don't know like really what
the game is all about because I just played
some I didn't go into like diving in lore
kind of [__] when I played right and so
like to not be familiar with the game really
it doesn't feel like it's I it isolates or
there wasn't anything happening here going
I don't know I don't know you know like there
didn't feel like there was a ton of Easter
eggs that we were just like missing yeah and
they knew how to handle expositions so well
where I was never lost on what was happening
in this movie despite a bunch of new names
a bunch of new worlds a bunch of new creatures
and stuff it was a bunch of new stuff and
it it never felt like I'm playing a game of
trying to keep up they managed to just imbue
everything within the the heart and the soul
of the journey the entire time right yeah
it's a solid ass movie I I don't know what
I I don't know what I would would don't like
about it I can't that's what I was saying
I'm like there's nothing that I didn't enjoy
because I like that the women were saving
the guys there wasn't a ton of exposition
there was a lot of Comedy that was done really
well in regards to the pacing the heart never
felt like where they were trying to give even
when Michelle Rodriguez goes in to get closure
it's like you kind of it's not it doesn't
feel like ah they added this in and it's not
working it it worked and it it I just yeah
there's no there wasn't any problems with
it for me ah yeah I guess uh I felt the stakes
but I guess I would have liked a clearer sense
of the villain I don't know I feel like I'm
just looking for something that I didn't really
think double villain yeah there's like a little
like villain on top of villain and then yeah
it's like I feel more I feel more personal
hatred towards Hugh Grant than you did the
the crazy red witch lady yeah yeah where she
was like the real threat um but I I felt more
towards huge I don't know I guess my there's
a slight imbalance of where to place my dislike
and I'm really kind of just looking for something
really searching right now and I think he
can be done with it let's see what it got
I would I would give it like a 95 to tell
you the 97 okay just a one up here click it
let's see click it come on now 91. holy [__]
that is yeah absolutely awesome it deserves
it heck yeah man 93 audience great that's
what I mean man I was watching it and I'm
like who would not who are the who okay how
many critics they're 286 critics 27 who are
you 20. he's 27. who are you has sons of [__]
they can't understand great camera work and
fun adventure escapism just overwhelming dear
Lord of the Rings not go what Source materials
something that's built on imagination creativity
but they didn't sense much of in honor among
Thieves I found the experience a bit mundane
I'm like what do you do on a daily basis to
where you uh do you think this movie is mundane
I'm like are you just jumping out of planes
every day and like writing stuff about movies
but like the self-conscious I thought this
movie was so confident what I don't know who
these words I don't know who you people are
I don't trust any of you here I don't trust
any of you I I love this movie you guys this
movie's great yeah I was like a crazy they
can get out of here the critic the audience
score is insanely high on it too as it should
be yeah great fantasy Adventure man and uh
it looks awesome too from beginning to end
so did hop Bridgerton he looks great too he
was Charming I I didn't I never finished Bridgerton
I only got five episodes into the first season
everyone says it's season two is when it gets
great it does it gets moving it gets it gets
grooving I don't yeah I just couldn't get
through the first season I was like the same
my jam
I thought those two people were awful yeah
is he in season two yeah okay and he's some
hot stuff huh yeah so is Chris Chris is super
cute real funny who's Chris you know Pine
that one oh yeah yeah yeah that Chris yeah
he's good at playing those Scoundrels man
he's so he's so good at that he has like a
very specific archetype yeah like from Captain
Kurt to this guy he's very very specific but
he could also do [__] like don't worry
darling and everything like that but these
kind of roles are when he does Excel he's
also something like hell or high water these
kind of roles is when I think he just absolutely
he's got this like Natural Energy and and
it it really does like command the screen
but he never what what's great about him in
ensembles is he always does he never seems
like he's trying to steal away from the rest
of the cast right he does like allow himself
to elevate yeah he's excellent yeah absolutely
excellent he's great at connecting with others
and Sophia lillis was nice to see her here
Justice Smith also great rooting for him man
what a wonderful Fantastical world so many
different kinds of creatures I love that it's
way better than that rings of power show so
good alrighty guys well what did you guys
think about this movie did you love it as
much as Tara and I had an absolute blast with
this one um I hope they make a sequel did
it do all right at the point that's the last
thing we'll check did it Duo right at the
Box off I hope it's like a huge enough streaming
hit that it at least allows for a sequel
domestic attack great so far huh I mean yeah
let's do that correct because it came out
I forgot there was some movie that came out
like a week after that was like bound to just
knock it out of like the box office like the
release time for this yes this is an expensive
budget it's not going to make something better
it's not looking likely um hopefully it becomes
big enough though because yeah that was a
blast that was a blast sorry guys well we
loved it what'd you guys think leave your
thoughts down below subscribe follow Tara
on the socials last but not least terribly
help me do it
Gabriel what's funny about Gabriel John and
I were constantly make the Archangel Gabriel
jokes oh but then Gabriel was like he had
a Canada with these I'm an atheist oh so Tara
can you shout out our atheist friend Gabriel
yeah maintaining why it's great to to be an
atheist well it's great to be an atheist yeah
it's I mean just like believe in yourself
you know in love and friends and friendship
and like we don't need to get wrapped up in
all the other Jews so I support you 100 are
the other Jews all the other Jews oh juice
juice I thought you were saying Jews yeah
get out of here get out of here all the other
juice we don't got to worry about it Greg
okay I'm still hearing Jews and I think that's
really really hey that's your problem you
need you need to take a back seat okay because
I have never said I don't even why do I need
no juice I use the word juice all the time
and he knows it Gregory Alba knows how much
I use the word juice and he's choosing not
to hear it so this is this is what our friendship
is ladies and gentlemen okay this is what
this is what is that friendship I don't I
don't know that I both lost at all times
Gabriel you don't want to be over here okay
you don't just don't get this is not pleasant
no this is not fun for anybody I don't know
why you're supporting us all this time when
we've tried converting you to Catholicism
or Judaism this entire time right yeah it's
not a son Holy Spirit got it and if you want
to add a little extra cherry on top amen a
Crossing between there amen okay all right
a little flame of that candle you know what
I mean get some extra points with God in heaven
okay yeah yeah Gabriel listen it's okay to
be atheist nothing happens when you die congratulations
I mean do we really want something I really
want something I'd rather be nothing when
all this is done just nice and dark just like
it did it's like a blackout you just get punched
blackout you remember nothing it's done good
what do you believe when you die Gabriel what
do you think happens
maybe there's like a bright light or something
you know maybe it's not dark it's bright it
might be like nice like I haven't you know
like that kind of a thing I don't know that's
what you think an atheist is gonna get but
like it I have it like differently like it's
like why he walks into it and then then maybe
it's blackout like it's like a TV like static
TV maybe and they find out they're just in
a Toyota car dealership yeah that sounds atheist
to me yeah and then they gotta go like sell
cars but they're like I'd rather do that than
be in a weird land filled with flowers in
clouds you know another sell some Toyotas
then yeah lots of money oh yeah right yeah
yeah and then Gabriel can use that money to
up his pledge exactly that would be perfect
Gabriel get get in there sell some sell some
more car car cars and get some more juice
again Canon we're talking about the Jews we
don't need that kind of heat on us friendship
we got three people here who come on now who
are Jewish it's tough this guy it's tough
he really he it's not something he he he he
just pushes me into a corner and then he's
just like I hope you can find your way out
that is not a good thing to say about a man
publicly on the internet
I do not push Tara into corners and threaten
her support with his words alrighty you've
earned your solid two and a half hours according
to this timer Tara see you guys soon thanks
Gabriel for being here [Music]